welcome to this video playing a DD or
probably not pronouncing this correctly
from France it's at least a French
sounding name and the French flag and we
got the English Defence their own
defenses sir quite quite interesting
only G 30 i'll jump right in and so what
now c5 sometimes c5 is good in these
positions now oops looks like an active
youth
96 96 94 probably not not to be
recommended
now no no no knight c6 increasing the
pressure even that looks rather rather
active for black
hmm
yeah just struck c8 I mean that's not
bad of the seafoam this rook opposing
the Queen f form
f4 hmm
but I'm bad I'm just a bit a bit
surprised by this move look so very
weakening let's open up the position
here the Queen here opposite it's really
irritating me
95 from strong me not so great can play
d 6 yeah okay keep it simple shouldn't
be too bad I know that the e6 porn looks
slightly ugly okay he just he just play
some something else and I thought I
thought about taking mostly ok let's try
to get some active play going here yeah
maybe Queen III now I didn't look at
this too closely
hmm yeah just just grab it I take here
and d5 he's got queen to III m2 were to
defend
fatigue and she takes d5 it takes you
four and Quincy seven it's also looking
good yeah why not actually Queen III now
take c4s protecting e6 at least got no
way to protect the c-4 night
quindi six looks very very shaky okay
let's go to this brilliant square just
just excellent now
so how to how to continue maybe I'm
let's let's just get some more space for
the king I want to I don't want to
exchange so much yeah okay attending h3
and switching to a king side attack or a
check on the king this it's probably
strong
introducing queen g2
he's only got one check in between be to
Quincy two wins the Queen
check check and Roxy to hopefully this
is winning yeah guess so Queenie to
Queen f2 and rock the tudors Roxy one
made next move yeah I looked at it it
looked like an active position for Black
Sun not clear how wide um should
procedure Matt some I'm also just better
developed for some reason I don't know
he moved the screen moves Quincy to
Quincy three many pawn moves like a
three and so on I don't know that that
looks like looks like a good a good good
position this this is of course very
aggressive but also probably good you
need to get going as long as it's not
coordinated sort of get him with his
pants down and this is just just winning
probably yeah yeah I think this was
rather rather okay didn't don't think he
had much really yeah thanks for watching